so this lot I can feel one of two ways
about it one it's the place where I lost
my uncle to gun violence but two I'm
like hopeful about it right because it's
just untapped potential it's really how
you look at the spaces in your community
Maidan Brownsville is a nonprofit youth
creative agency to increase access to
design and technology professions for
young people
right now we're working with a local
organization to help young people design
urban furniture that deals with wellness
and getting people active and talking to
one another we live too often the people
where the decisions are made aren't from
the place so they don't have a vested
interest in its outcome but we live here
so we can and we should guys proud of
yourselves
[Applause]
right now we are headed Howard Gardens
it's a space that really shaped my
perception of public space growing up I
think when I think about the space in
terms of defining the work that I do now
it's like the first example I feel like
I remember of someone local carrying
enough to take vacant space and and make
it an asset and I think that that's like
shaped the course of you know my career
you see you're not going to get
everybody anticipating and you know but
if you get one out of maybe ten then
you've done something like yourself
instance I consider you very successful
and come a long way and naturally if you
can do something for someone that's good
you keep doing it you don't stop it I
think like most marginalized communities
Brownsville is faced with the same
social conditions that come with poverty
health the crime housing conditions but
within those barriers people are
inventive and resilient what I Drive
passion from is changing the narrative
around the identity of this place wait
how can I help other people see the
beauty that I see in this neighborhood
where we're headed it's called a youth
Clubhouse is conceived of by young
people and live in this housing
development taking back what was a
vacant lot and repurposing it to be a
community asset this project you know
always gets me like you know butterfly I
don't know is somewhere in this
neighborhood there's 14 young people
that can say I made this I brought this
to life that is powerful
[Music]
if you look at Brownsville's history it
was always a great place to live and
work right now it's a great place to
live but we want to bring back all those
lost industries where we need it the
most
our most recent graphic design cohort
they are all from the brownsville ocean
hill area what made in brownsville is
doing for them is taking their existing
talent and we're giving them a technical
skill that allows them to take their
careers to the next level
[Music]
when I typically tell young people is
that they have a particular genius that
they can only unlock they have the world
at their disposal walking them a number
on so every day makes me feel like I'm
gonna be something in life if Manny
Brownsville wasn't here I would never
thought about doing anything like this I
would never thought about thinking about
being a photographer
my vision for Brownsville isn't too
dissimilar from what already exists but
it's also you know thinking about what
it looks like to safely occupy public
space equitably and all that is
absolutely possible through local folks
with the political will and enough
agency to determine and define their
future if you're watching this video
right now I would tell you to dream as
big of a vision for yourself as possible
the future is boundless
[Music]
you